on va jouer un jeu très que j'aime
beaucoup c'est le sait le beer pong
wayne fait c'est le pire pont de pierre
dont on est là en face de l'autre 3 2
balles de ping pong
ouais on lance la balle ouais si on la
met dans le gobelet fort rebond il faut
un rebond là et un rebond l'iphone durer
longtemps possible si ça tombe dans le
gobelet l'adversaire d'en face est
éliminé mais surtout il boit michael 7e
chose mais c'est quoi ces regards
croisés dégueulasse non non non c
passable comme ça c'est devant lui il
dit comme ça c'est comestibles mais ce n
est pas cela très beau diable
voilà bah ouais c'est bientôt car papa
les ai jamais joué ou quoi
alors non pas loin d'atteindre galata
n'est pas droite émilie vous devez voir
ça
en france ça reste allez hop et elle le
voit vraiment à l'écoulement deuxième
partie faire ce qu'on appelle du close
up close up c'est la magie très
rapprochées règles on connaît le coz à
vous connaissez très bien raccords pour
cela on a besoin d'un jeu de cartes vous
venez on va se rapprocher de la caméra
dorsale avec des cartes top toute
différente on est d'accord alors
benjamin vous le placez votre doux à
l'intérieur et une sélection d'une carte
vraiment au hasard attention allez-y go
c'est très bon sur le doigt on doit hop
vous regardez la carte voulait montrer à
tout le monde sauf à moi et vous
l'imprimé dans votre esprit en retourne
il est à fougax hockey ou la place et il
s'attend à caen attend de toi et d'après
la confiance ce congrès voilà on est ici
d'accord ok très bien pour l'année ce
qui se passe bien posée à l'intérieur je
prend la première carte la croisière
c'est ma carte c'est le 2 2 carreaux
très bien le 2k rouges de pol un vote le
2 carreaux passe ici est que votre carte
pass juste là si on n en a pas d or les
quais plus bas sont concentrés la casse
avait toujours là et se tourne beaucoup
en bois sa diatribe l'honneur une gorgée
une gorgée seulement les gars c'était
que dacia fait qu'apple se côtoyaient
tafer qui à tout et non alors qu'est ce
qui a changé
pour voir ce solde a dominé l'espanol
montréal à laval à égalité attention je
gagne à la sirène est bien là perdu à
l'intérieur c'est juste ça elle remonte
sur le dessus alors au moins sur le sud
alors le but du jeu c'est la faire
disparaître
et c'est plus compliqué vous êtes
monsieur bien on fait un deux trois oui
mais à meyrals et la carte va me
véritablement disparaître deux pays en
main dessus
la carte est disparue la personne ne
croit bien évidemment non regardez et la
carte vraiment s'est dissipée vous savez
pourquoi
non parce que si je fais ça ouvrez
ouvrez votre bouchard est allé de danse
elle est dedans c'est vrai elle est
dedans je faisais la fermeture mais
après tout doucement fait pas plus la
caméra le montre bien le gardien d'une
seule bernard way
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hélas en approchez vous regardez bien
ces deux fois toutes les cartes françois
mollat
alors là
l'effort maxi maxi maxime maxime j'ai un
conseil arrêtez les médias m'a fait trop
fade mais vous êtes largement meilleur
en magie dans média avec isabelle jeu
peut durer des heures et j'étais pas
loin
ouais mais bon il faut pas être pas loin
il faut être dedans ouais c'est ça ouais
comme avec alain attendrait toujours les
habitants à les raisons de cette chance
d'avancer qualifié la plainte après que
vous rejoins les jeannois
c'est quoi ce que ce monsieur c'est ça
les acomptes pour venir ces dernières
allaient assez dégueu la main ensuite si
je remporte cette partie vous gagnez
l'imprimante portable
attention
[Applaudissements]
à